a big day today here in nevada we take
another step in the long climb back to
some sense of normal john alex bars
restaurants gyms and other businesses
here in southern nevada can now move to
half capacity
hector mejia is live this morning to
show us how these new rules are going to
work for us hyper good morning
good morning and the change took effect
at midnight all businesses now
allowed to go from 35 capacity up to 50
percent
that might not sound like a lot but for
local business owners it is a pretty big
deal
we talked with a local restaurant over
at table 34 executive chef
wes kendrick says safety is still a high
priority
he wants to make sure guests feel
comfortable every time they visit so
they can keep coming back
but kendrick says the new capacity
limits mean he can have more people at
each table
which will help keep his business
running
50 percent for us will be about you know
60 people in the room which would be
great
and we still have them socially distant
so i think i think that's reasonable and
it's a step in the right direction and
we're very
much looking forward to it
so the new rules apply to everything
from casinos to libraries to shopping
malls
as for big gatherings those are now 250
people or half of a venue's fire code
capacity
we've already seen the curtain rise on
more than 30 shows here on the las vegas
strip where we're live this morning
these new rules should hopefully allow
more shows to return
soon and nothing changes as far as
wearing a mask or social distancing
that stays the same even though some
states have started to relax those rules
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now